[Musique]
veaux légers là je brasse le maximum de
narnia en tunique
[Musique]
je veux voir ce jusqu'à la meilleure
maîtrise de soi merci madame deux
minutes en étant pressing soudainement
de septembre je suis dans clientèle
j'arrive dans deux minutes merci oui
s'il vous plaît c'est loupé je suis en
clientèle s'il vous plaît écoutez je
vais vous expliquer ce qu'on va faire on
va voir qui a la meilleure maîtrise de
soi vous allez devoir chercher la boule
de l'adar cas elle va falloir être très
très très courageux et serrurerie quant
à la bourboule de l'adar cas lors de
notre retour
la paris un cadeau exceptionnel
pourquoi l'ordre lors de notre retour à
paris parce qu'il faut me laisser ton
trouvait être teco2 et jack o
merci à nos trois danseuses magnifique
de tout de suite levé le voile à la mode
arcade se trouve là l'égérie je vais
vous demander d'aller un parent désigner
celui vous allez envoyer pour aller
chercher la boule de l'adar cas excusez
moi qui vous a demandé de vous lever
jules césar le train soit de dzeko
nuit-là 160 ans
je vais d'abord envoyé motards qui va et
voter parce que j'ai pas autant que j'ai
de quoi n'ai pas bien compris donc je
suis un petit peu
mokhtar tu vas voter en son âme et
conscience me moctar votre bien parce
que si celui qui désigne ne trouve pas
la boule de l'adar cas en moins de deux
minutes ça sera le séjour de la race
rare
asie mokhtar je t'aime bien mais jamais
le colorado
castaldi
normalement à cette heure-ci ses amis
jack et d'alien déjà fortement frappé il
s'appuiera rien
isabelle parce qu'il est courageux parce
qu'il est aucune limite parce qu'il
serait couvert les quatre membres pour
ses rimes garde le cinquième ville de
vote pour cette personne parce que
peut-être que comme ça une fois dans sa
vie elle sera courage aussi
[Musique]
les séries c'est sûr que tu as une trace
mais bien sûr j'ai demandé à jean-michel
aller voter maxime
caroline
notre unique au
elle frappe à la barre
[Musique]
je pense qu'il sera
plus habile
à la chasse au serpent sont clos
je vais procéder au dépouillement pour
savoir qui va aller chercher la boule de
l'adar cas il aura deux minutes
attention donc gynéco
doc gynéco lot maxime way
isaure
de vote pour doc gynéco a pour isa pour
maxime juin
[Musique]
j'ai deux
doc qui fait le break avec trois votes
et ce vote peut déjà être décisif si ces
docks doc tu sera désigné et c'est très
important
ouais c'est toi qui aura tout le
programme entre les mains puisque tu
seras désigner la personne qui devra
aller chercher la boule la bouboule la
bourboule acquis il ya beaucoup de la
partie
ces deux encore bâbord mais tu auras un
magnifique cadeau en plateau mais
vraiment très très beau cadeau en vrai
donc tu as peur des serpents en général
bah oui dans quatre à sion tu as deux
minutes
attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
labeaume attend de faire plus vite que
les pertes ont même cherché cette boule
il reste quand même temps
ça fait vingt secondes non mais c'est
pas sa principale qualité il à être
rapide
mais bon là
ah bon
[Applaudissements]
bingo
doc gynéco bravo il faut être plus tueur
a montré que tu étais exceptionnel on
t'aime énormément je déclare la dark a
ouverte
nous
elle passait en
la bouboule de la marque à doc gynéco
grâce à vous vous l'avez ramener